well the economic situation in the
united states has taken a very
interesting turn and in particular if
you believe as i believe the evidence
shows that one of the greatest
indicators as to how a particular
election is going to go
is the perception of how the economy is
doing
things are all of a sudden looking quite
okay for democrats and not so good for
republicans
if the average person actually
understands what's going on and i want
to start by looking at the first
interesting indicator for today and that
is gas prices gas prices have now
continued to fall for nearly 60 days in
a row and are below four dollars per
gallon for the first time since march of
2022 now why are gas prices so important
because
is are is gasoline really a major
expense for most households and the
answer is not directly
certainly if you're in transportation
uber drivers
etc it's a major thing if you have a
long commute it's a major thing
but there's two reasons why this is
important number one many people look at
gas prices as a general proxy towards
are things cheaper expensive right now
and when gas is 502 per gallon as it was
two months ago
there is the perception that things are
generally expensive and when gas now
drops below four dollars a gallon
there's the perception that things are
cheaper we know things are cheaper
because inflation has started to come
down but there's another issue with gas
prices which is so many of the things
that we depend on food products of
different kinds so many different things
they come on trucks and are affected by
gas prices as well so this is an
important indicator for that reason and
when we look at the gas buddy price
charts you will see that there was this
peak at about 502 per gallon late in
actually early in june and then it has
been a continued and steady decline now
below four dollars per gallon to what
looks like let me see officially what
cnn says 399 per gallon as of this
morning according to triple a so let's
now take a deeper look at some of these
economic indicators if you step back and
you think about over the last two weeks
what have we seen well we've seen the
stock market increase nicely
we've seen a blockbuster jobs report
where a quarter of a million jobs were
expected in july and we got over five
hundred thousand jobs more than doubling
the expectation inflation is down
gas prices are down the inflation
reduction act has been signed the pack
or will the inflation reduction act has
been uh voted uh approved by the senate
and then tomorrow presumably will be
approved by the house and very quickly
signed by joe biden the pact act
has been signed um wages are up
and then on the other hand you have
donald trump raided by the fbi with
pictures of his toilet with documents in
its circulating as he pled the fifth
yesterday more than 400 times when
deposed by the new york attorney general
things aren't looking very good for
trump world and things are looking
increasingly good for joe biden now
is it good that gas prices are low
one of the things that we have to
understand
is that it's not necessarily good for
the long term for gas to be so cheap in
the united states i've said before
gasoline prices in the united states are
not accurate in the sense of
representing the true cost of a gallon
of gas particularly including the
environmental cost of a gallon of gas
when gas is more expensive
people tend to use less of it and when
you look at europe you see smaller
vehicles and people being much more
judicious in terms of their road trips
i've done road trips and done extensive
driving in let me think now spain
france
italy
um
at minimum if not other places as well
and with tiny vehicles i mean tiny
vehicles compact cars little stick shift
compact cars that i rent
it's stunning when i don't drive that
much and the gas bill is 70 euro
and if in the united states gas prices
were similar to those in europe which
are arguably more accurate in
representing the true cost of a gallon
of gas
people would drive a lot less and we
would be doing less damage to the
environment and so while by traditional
economic standards inflation down gas
prices down stocks up all of this stuff
looks good
for biden
i also am painfully aware of the fact
that higher gas prices encourage people
to get off of gas powered vehicles and
move over to electrics to drive less to
look for a more fuel efficient vehicle
so
these are all double-edged swords but by
the standard indicators we look at
things are looking really good doesn't
mean there isn't poverty inequality lack
of access to health care of course we
haven't solved the economy overnight but
many of the indicators republicans
themselves look at are looking very very
good